Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. There she was, the world's highest paid fashion model, snubbing the ironclad conventions of fashionable Flemington with a dress five inches above the knee. No hat, no gloves and no stockings. For my money, she looked tremendous. But Flemington was not amused fashion conscious derby day race goers were horrified insulting a disgrace how dare she if the skies had rained acid not a well-dressed woman there would have given the shrimp an umbrella that Dominic was the Melbourne Sun News pictorial reporting on what I think we both of us would agree is one of the world's most important
感谢收听《历史就是如此》。想要获取每周的额外剧集、无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。当时，世界上薪酬最高的时装模特就站在那里，她无视弗莱明顿赛马场那些根深蒂固的时尚传统，穿了一件裙摆高出膝盖五英寸的连衣裙。没戴帽子，没戴手套，也没穿丝袜。在我看来，她看起来棒极了。但弗莱明顿赛马场可不这么认为，那些有时尚意识的德比日赛马观众感到震惊，称这是一种侮辱，是一种耻辱，她怎么敢这样。如果当时天空下的是酸雨，那里没有一个衣着考究的女士会给这只“小虾米”撑伞。多米尼克，这就是《墨尔本太阳新闻画报》对这件事的报道，我想我们俩都会同意，这是世界上最重要的事件之一
episodes in history, rivaled perhaps only by the Battle of Crecy. I think so. In the list of top historical events. For me, Tom, there are three great events in history. There was the Battle of Crecy. Yeah, of course. There was the Battle of Melbourne when Gene Shrimpton was a dress that's slightly too short. And there is Wolves inventing European football in the 1950s.
历史上的剧集，或许只有克雷西战役能与之媲美。我也这么认为。在历史重大事件的名单中。对我来说，汤姆，历史上只有三件大事。一个是克雷西战役。是的，当然。一个是吉恩·什林普顿穿了一件稍微太短的裙子而引发的“墨尔本战役”。还有一个是狼队在20世纪50年代发明了欧洲足球。
Okay, well, that means nothing to me. But I think the first two, I'd agree with you. So this is the incredible cliffhanger on which we left listeners at the end of the last episode. Unbelievable cliffhanger. And now, Dominic, you are going to reveal what happens in Melbourne. What has Jean Shrimpton, the shrimp, done? This supermodel, the world's most beautiful girl she's gone to Melbourne and what is it that happens at the races she's done something
好吧，这对我来说毫无意义。但我认为前两件事，我同意你的看法。所以这就是我们在上一集结尾留给听众的那个令人难以置信的悬念。不可思议的悬念。现在，多米尼克，你要揭晓墨尔本发生了什么。吉恩·什林普顿，那个“小虾米”，做了什么？这位超级名模，世界上最美丽的女孩，她去了墨尔本，在赛马场上到底发生了什么？她做了一些
absolutely extraordinary Tom she has gone to the Melbourne race course on derby day in a white shift dress made from the synthetic all-on fabric that she's been paid two thousand pounds to advertise and they haven't given her enough fabric so she's been paid £2,000 to advertise, and they haven't given her enough fabric. So she's designed it herself, and her hemline ends just above her knee, so a few inches above her knee, and she has no stockings, as that beautifully read Australian newspaper editorial says. No gloves and no stockings, absolutely scandalous behavior and the the matrons of melbourne and australia is quite a conservative place in the 1960s so this is the place that
绝对非同寻常的事情，汤姆。她在德比日去了墨尔本赛马场，穿了一件由合成纤维面料制成的白色直筒裙，她收了两千英镑的广告费来宣传这种面料，但他们给她的布料不够，所以她收了2000英镑的广告费，但他们给她的布料不够。于是她自己设计了这件裙子，裙摆刚好在膝盖上方，也就是膝盖上方几英寸处，而且正如那篇写得极好的澳大利亚报纸社论所说，她没穿丝袜。没戴手套，也没穿丝袜，这绝对是伤风败俗的行为。墨尔本的那些贵妇们，而且澳大利亚在20世纪60年代是一个相当保守的地方，所以这就是
your clive jameses and your dame edna's and your germaine greer's are trying to leave because they think it's too stuffing conservative and people in melbourne are outraged by this absolutely outraged the british newspapers are delighted so one british newspaper said surrounded by sober draped silks and floral nylons ghastly tool hats and fur stoles she looked like a petunia in an onion patch so this is the kind of commentary that always endears British newspapers to Australian readers. So, Jean Shrimpton has turned up in this white shift dress, and this apparently scandalous appearance makes the front page of every newspaper in Australia, and indeed in Britain. And it is seen often as the moment the miniskirt was invented, which is actually weird
你的克莱夫·詹姆斯、埃德娜夫人和杰曼·格里尔们正试图离开的地方，因为他们觉得这里太沉闷保守了。墨尔本的人们对此感到愤怒，绝对的愤怒。英国报纸却很高兴，所以一家英国报纸写道：在清醒的垂坠丝绸、花卉尼龙、可怕的薄纱帽子和皮草披肩的包围下，她看起来就像洋葱地里的一朵矮牵牛花。所以，这就是那种总是让英国报纸受到澳大利亚读者喜爱的评论。所以，吉恩·什林普顿穿着这件白色直筒裙出现了，这种看似伤风败俗的装扮登上了澳大利亚乃至英国每一份报纸的头版。它通常被视为迷你裙诞生的时刻，这其实很奇怪
because she's not wearing a miniskirt because it's a little dress. But it demonstrates, does it not, Dominic, in the words of Vogue, that brevity is the soul of fashion. Oh, very good, Tom. Very good quotation. Reading off your notes there.
因为她穿的并不是迷你裙，而是一件小裙子。但这难道不正如《Vogue》所言，证明了简洁是时尚的灵魂吗，多米尼克？哦，说得好，汤姆。引用得非常好。你是照着笔记念的吧。
Yes, no. So there has been a move generally. We were talking about this in the last episode with the foundation of Mary Quant's boutique Bazaar in 1955 with the growing kind of infantilization of fashion, which I think is going to become an even more pronounced theme in this episode. There's been a move towards a much more informal look, much lighter, more colorful. I was about to say more sexualized.
是的，没错。所以总的来说有一种趋势。我们在上一集讨论过这个问题，1955年玛丽·匡特在伦敦开设了“集市”精品店，随着时尚日益呈现出一种幼稚化的倾向，我认为这在这一集中会成为一个更加显著的主题。时尚界已经转向了一种更加随意、更加轻盈、更加多彩的风格。我正想说，更加性感化。
It's more sexualized, but in a very peculiar way. So it's sort of childlike sexuality. So mini skirts and mini dresses come out of that. So people have been experimenting for a few years with shift dresses and with shorter skirts. And the Sunday Times, their fashion correspondent, Ernestine Carter, had said that 1963 was the year of the leg. And this sort of stuff is in the air but when gene shrimpson goes to melbourne in october 1965 that's the moment when it really explodes into kind of global consciousness and then of course mini skirts are everywhere and they become emblematic of this sort of exciting new but it is basically
它确实更加性感化了，但方式非常奇特。所以这是一种类似孩童般的性感。因此，迷你裙和迷你连衣裙就是由此产生的。所以人们已经尝试了几年直筒裙和更短的裙子。而《星期日泰晤士报》的时尚记者欧内斯汀·卡特曾说过，1963年是“美腿之年”。这种风气在当时弥漫开来，但当吉恩·什林普顿在1965年10月去墨尔本时，那一刻它真正爆发并进入了全球意识，然后当然，迷你裙随处可见，它们成为了这种令人兴奋的新事物的象征，但它基本上
a british invention then i think it's fair to say it's a British invention, yeah. So it's up there with parliamentary democracy, industrial revolution. Yeah, exactly. The King James Bible. King James Bible. Absolutely it is, Tom. Brilliant. So proud. So proud. It's just under two years since the Beatles went to New York, which is a transformational moment in the image of British youth culture culture abroad and a genuinely transformational moment so before that point uh british pop culture had had very little sway overseas after the beatles trip to new york obviously you have the british invasion um bands enjoying extraordinary success
是一个英国发明，所以我认为说是英国发明是公平的，是的。所以它和议会民主制、工业革命并列。是的，完全正确。钦定版圣经。钦定版圣经。绝对是这样，汤姆。太棒了。真骄傲。真骄傲。距离披头士乐队去纽约还不到两年，那对英国青年文化在海外的形象是一个转折点，也是一个真正具有变革意义的时刻。所以在那之前，英国流行文化在海外的影响力很小。在披头士去纽约之后，显然你有了“英伦入侵”，乐队们取得了非凡的成功
not just in america but in almost every western country um and people are looking to britain they're affecting British slang copying British fashion copying the fashion that the pop stars wear and so yeah I think you can absolutely say at this point 1965 that Britain is setting the tone internationally but most of I mean most of the Beatles obviously but Rolling Stones and Kinks, who I sang at the beginning of the last episode and so on, are male. But the look of the 60s is female. Yes, I think that's fair to say. The sound of the 60s is male.
不仅是在美国，几乎在每一个西方国家。人们开始关注英国，模仿英国俚语，模仿英国时尚，模仿流行歌星穿的衣服。所以是的，我认为你绝对可以说在1965年这个节点，英国正在引领国际潮流。但大部分，我是说披头士显然是主力，但滚石乐队和奇想乐队——我在上一集开头唱过他们的歌——等等，都是男性。但60年代的造型是女性化的。是的，我认为这很公平。60年代的声音是男性的。
The look of the 60s is female. A guy called Peter Lorre wrote a book in 1965, in that year, called The Teenage Revolution. And he said the real dynamo of the teenage revolution is the teenage girl, the girl aged between, let's say, 13 and 18 or 13 and 21, as people probably said in those days, who has more spending power than anybody of her age previously in history, has more freedom, probably has a job after school or the weekends, has money in her pockets, is reading these magazines that we were talking about last time, like Valentine or Honey, the biggest of these magazines in Britain, is buying the pop records. Yeah. So the Beatles audiences, those gigs in 1963, they're screaming of Beatlemania. I mean, there are boys in the audience too. There are young men in the audience, but it's the young women who get all the attention,
60年代的造型是女性化的。一个叫彼得·洛里的人在1965年写了一本书，就在那一年，书名叫《青少年革命》。他说青少年革命真正的动力是十几岁的女孩，也就是年龄在13到18岁，或者当时人们可能说的13到21岁之间的女孩，她们比历史上任何同龄人都有更多的消费能力，有更多的自由，可能在放学后或周末有工作，口袋里有钱，在读我们上次谈到的那些杂志，比如《情人》或《蜂蜜》，这是英国最大的几本杂志，在买流行唱片。是的。所以披头士的观众，1963年的那些演出，那是披头士狂热的尖叫声。我是说，观众里也有男孩。观众里有年轻男性，但引起所有关注的是年轻女性，
who drive the sales. So the Beatles famously wear suits. They're put in suits by Brian Epstein. Yeah. Which is a kind of slightly mod type thing, I would have said. Right. And thinking about, I guess, the most kind of emblematic British TV show of the 60s, The Avengers, Patrick Minney playing John Steed in The Avengers wears a suit and a bowler
是她们推动了销售。所以披头士乐队以穿西装闻名。他们是被布莱恩·爱泼斯坦穿上西装的。是的。那是一种稍微有点摩登风格的东西，我会这么说。没错。想到，我想，60年代最具代表性的英国电视剧《复仇者》，帕特里克·麦尼在《复仇者》中饰演约翰·斯蒂德，穿着西装和圆顶
hat. He does indeed. He looks like the archetype of a British gentleman. Yes. But Diana Rigg playing Emma Peel, I mean, she's all about leather and plastic and all that kind of thing. Well, here's the interesting thing. At first, she wears leather. So The Avengers is a really good example to pick because it's the first British TV show.
礼帽。他确实如此。他看起来就像英国绅士的原型。是的。但戴安娜·里格饰演的艾玛·皮尔，我的意思是，她全是关于皮革和塑料之类的东西。好吧，有趣的事情在这里。起初，她穿的是皮革。所以《复仇者》是一个很好的例子，因为它是第一部英国电视剧。
So we should just say what that is. It's a kind of faintly surreal, crime capers, spies. Yes, exactly. Set in swinging London. Very swinging London and ever more surreal plot. So it starts out and it's quite gritty. And as time goes on, as the 60s continues, the Avengers becomes more and more kind of...
所以我们应该先说一下那是什么。它是一种带有淡淡超现实色彩的犯罪闹剧、间谍片。是的，完全正确。背景设定在摇摆伦敦。非常摇摆的伦敦，情节越来越超现实。所以它刚开始时相当写实。随着时间的推移，随着60年代的继续，《复仇者》变得越来越……
The writers take more and more psychedelic drugs. Yeah, it becomes kind of bonkers and, as you say, very surreal and really fun and imaginative and it's very highly produced it's it's extremely expensive um by the standards of tv series of the day the outfits are a massive element of it so when diana rigg replaces honor blackman honor blackman goes off to make goldfinger the bond film again a real british pop cultural export to the 60s d Dinerig comes in to replace it. Now, Honor Blackman had already been wearing kind of leather, lots of leather, but Dinerig,
编剧们服用了越来越多的迷幻药。是的，它变得有点疯狂，正如你所说，非常超现实，真的很有趣且富有想象力，而且制作水平非常高，以当时电视剧的标准来看，它极其昂贵。服装是其中一个巨大的元素，所以当戴安娜·里格取代奥诺·布莱克曼时——奥诺·布莱克曼去拍邦德电影《金手指》了，这又是60年代一个真正的英国流行文化出口产品——戴安娜·里格进来接替了她。现在，奥诺·布莱克曼之前已经穿过皮革，大量的皮革，但戴安娜·里格，
the producers make a huge hullabaloo about what her clothes are going to be. And over time, they get rid of the leather catsuits and they bring in this sort of op art look. So op art, most people probably won't even know what that is because again that's something that has dated quite badly so there's an artist called bridget riley who would do these sort of slightly um mind bending geometric black and white patterns very space age she's still very big name oh she's very cool i i love all that stuff. Designers copied that in wallpaper, in fabrics, and particularly in clothes. So you'd wear black and white clothes, short skirts, as you said, lots of PVC, lots of plastic, because people are absolutely obsessed with this idea of clothes of the future. We didn't really talk about this last time, but in 1965, so again, the same year that Gene Shrimpton goes to Melbourne, there's a guy called Andre Correz who does this. By far the most globally reported kind of collection of clothes in the whole of the decade.
制片人们对她的服装将是什么样子大肆炒作。随着时间的推移，他们摆脱了皮革连体衣，引入了这种欧普艺术风格。所以欧普艺术，大多数人可能甚至不知道那是什么，因为那也是一种已经过时得很厉害的东西。所以有一位艺术家叫布里奇特·赖利，她会做这些稍微有点令人头晕的几何黑白图案，非常有太空时代感。她仍然是一个大人物。哦，她非常酷，我喜欢所有这些东西。设计师们在壁纸、面料，尤其是服装上模仿了这一点。所以你会穿黑白衣服，短裙，正如你所说，大量的PVC，大量的塑料，因为人们对这种未来服装的想法绝对着迷。我们上次没怎么谈这个，但在1965年，也就是吉恩·什林普顿去墨尔本的同一年，有一个叫安德烈·库雷热的人做了这个。这是整个十年中全球报道最多的服装系列。
And they were called kind of clothes of the future, space age clothes. And they are kind of absolute classic kind of, you know, I'm going to wear a plastic jumper, PVC trousers. This is what people are going to be wearing on Venus in the year 2017. We're all going to be taking holidays on Mars. People will wear space astronauts' helmets as standard. Jetpacks. Jetpacks.
它们被称为未来服装，太空时代服装。它们是那种绝对经典的，你知道，我要穿一件塑料套头衫，PVC裤子。这就是人们在2017年会在金星上穿的衣服。我们都将去火星度假。人们会把太空宇航员头盔作为标准配置。喷气背包。喷气背包。
And these clothes, obviously nobody dresses in spacesuits, but people do wear plastic kind of skirts and stuff. I mean, they don't wear them for very long because they realize how ludicrously impractical they are. But there is a great fascination with the op art and with the space age and with new synthetic fabrics. I mean, it's telling that Gene Simpson had gone to advertise a synthetic fabric in Melbourne. And Diana Rigg in The Avengers is wearing all that stuff, very brightly colored. While kickboxing and felling villains.
这些衣服，显然没人会穿宇航服，但人们确实会穿塑料裙子之类的东西。我的意思是，他们穿的时间并不长，因为他们意识到这些衣服是多么荒谬且不切实际。但人们对欧普艺术、太空时代和新型合成面料有着极大的迷恋。我的意思是，吉恩·什林普顿去墨尔本宣传一种合成面料，这很有说明意义。而《复仇者》里的戴安娜·里格穿着所有那些色彩鲜艳的衣服。同时还在踢拳和打倒恶棍。
While karate chopping villains, exactly. So 1965, I would say, is the moment when it reaches the sort of peak of the Austin Powers. Very swinging 60s. As you mentioned, Dolly Birds. Again, it's the infantilization, Tom. Yeah. So they have whitened faces. You would whiten your face.
同时还在空手道劈砍恶棍，没错。所以1965年，我会说是它达到奥斯汀·鲍尔斯那种巅峰的时刻。非常摇摆的60年代。正如你提到的，时髦女郎。同样，这是幼稚化，汤姆。是的。所以她们有涂白的面孔。你会把脸涂白。
You might wear white lipstick. And then your eyes, you would blacken around the eyes. Panda eyes. Panda eyes, huge eyelashes. And of course, a lot of people don't even think about this at the time. But the reason this appeals is basically it makes you look like a baby. It makes you look like a child. Never thought of that.
你可能会涂白色口红。然后你的眼睛，你会把眼周涂黑。熊猫眼。熊猫眼，巨大的睫毛。当然，很多人当时甚至没想过这一点。但这种风格之所以吸引人，基本上是因为它让你看起来像个婴儿。它让你看起来像个孩子。从没想过这一点。
With a very, very pale face and huge eyes, which is famously how small children look. It's carrying to the extreme the look that had first been pioneered by Mary Quant in the mid-1950s, which is, let's have everybody look like members of the Famous Five, sort of Enid Blyton. Yeah, but to be fair, I mean, the Famous Five aren't dressing up in PVC minis. No, they're not. Certainly George isn't. Did I read yesterday, Tom, that the BBC are going to redo the Famous Five? They are, with a Danish director. With a new woke version of The Famous Five. Well, no, I think the Danish director is famous for making kind of very violent films. Is it Lars von Trier?
有着一张非常非常苍白的脸和巨大的眼睛，这正是小孩子看起来的样子。这是将玛丽·匡特在20世纪50年代中期首次开创的风格推向了极致，那就是，让每个人看起来都像《著名五人组》的成员，类似伊妮德·布莱顿笔下的角色。是的，但公平地说，我是说，《著名五人组》并没有穿PVC迷你裙。不，他们没有。乔治肯定没有。汤姆，我昨天是不是读到BBC要重拍《著名五人组》？是的，由一位丹麦导演执导。拍一个新版的“觉醒”版《著名五人组》。好吧，不，我认为那位丹麦导演以拍摄非常暴力的电影而闻名。是拉斯·冯·提尔吗？
No, it's not Lars von Trier, but he's kind of in that ilk. But I would like to see The Famous Five done now in the 1960s. So put them in PVC space age outfits. That would be great. Yeah, that would be fantastic. And actually they're fighting, instead of fighting smugglers, they could be fighting pirate radio stations. Yes. Yeah, they wouldn't approve of pirate radio stations at all. They absolutely wouldn't. Anyway, Dominic, so you said that this is the image of the 60s that
不，不是拉斯·冯·提尔，但他属于那一类。但我很想看到现在的《著名五人组》设定在60年代。所以让他们穿上PVC太空时代服装。那会很棒。是的，那会太棒了。而且实际上他们在战斗，与其说是打击走私者，不如说是打击海盗电台。是的。是的，他们绝对不会赞成海盗电台。他们绝对不会。总之，多米尼克，所以你说这就是人们心目中60年代的形象，
people have. Austin Powers begins with him on Carnaby Street, I think. Oh, right. Yes. So Carnaby Street is a, it's a street off Regent Street in Soho. Yes. In the middle of London. Yeah.
奥斯汀·鲍尔斯电影开头就是他在卡纳比街，我想。哦，对。是的。所以卡纳比街是苏活区摄政街旁边的一条街。是的。在伦敦市中心。是的。
Why Carnaby Street? Presumably it's not famous before the 60s, is it? No, not at all. It's cheap and run down. And actually what drives Carnaby Street, fascinatingly,
为什么是卡纳比街？大概它在60年代之前不出名，对吧？不，一点也不。它很便宜而且破旧。实际上推动卡纳比街发展的，令人着迷的是，
is not women's clothes, it's men's clothes, really, I would say. So there are lots of boutiques. We talked last time about boutiques. There's a famous partnership called Fole and T's clothes, really, I would say. So there are lots of boutiques. We talked last time about boutiques. There's a famous partnership called Fole & Tuffin, Marion Fole & Sally Tuffin. They are part of this new wave of boutiques that are copying, really, what's happened in the 50s and early 60s in Mary Quant.
不是女装，而是男装，真的，我会这么说。所以有很多精品店。我们上次谈到了精品店。有一个著名的合伙企业叫Fole & Tuffin，玛丽恩·福尔和萨莉·塔芬。她们是这股新精品店浪潮的一部分，她们实际上是在模仿50年代和60年代初玛丽·匡特所做的事情。
And they're establishing their new shops in rundown areas. And they choose a backwater called Carnaby Street. But what actually really turbocharges Carnaby Street is men's fashion. So there's a guy called John Stephen. John Stephen is the son of a Glaswegian shopkeeper. He had moved to London, as so many bright people did in the post-war years, to pursue his dreams. He works as a tailor's clerk.
她们在破旧地区建立了新店。她们选择了一个叫卡纳比街的死水区。但真正让卡纳比街起飞的实际上是男装。所以有一个叫约翰·斯蒂芬的人。约翰·斯蒂芬是一个格拉斯哥店主的儿子。他像战后那些聪明人一样搬到了伦敦，去追求他的梦想。他做过裁缝店职员。
He sets up his own boutique, which is called His Clothes. And he becomes the king. People call him the king of Carnaby Street, because what he's doing is he is selling the equivalent of all the things we've been describing, but for men. So very brightly colored, jolly. The codswallop fashions of perverted peacocks, I read as one description of them. By the menswear association. Someone's toes are being trodden on the menswear association are probably still trying to sell you quite heavy overcoats and very highly properly tailored clothes I mean the thing with John Stevens clothes I hope we're not going to be sued by him or his estate they're really cheap and they fell apart but they were cheerful yeah they were cheap and cheerful I mean it was basically his shops are
他开了自己的精品店，叫“他的衣服”。他成了国王。人们称他为卡纳比街之王，因为他所做的是销售我们一直在描述的所有东西的等价物，但针对的是男性。所以非常鲜艳，快乐。我读到过一种描述，称其为“变态孔雀的胡言乱语时尚”。来自男装协会。有人被踩到了脚趾，男装协会可能还在试图向你推销相当厚重的大衣和非常考究的定制服装。我的意思是，约翰·斯蒂芬衣服的问题是——我希望我们不会被他和他的遗产起诉——它们真的很便宜，而且容易散架，但它们很欢快。是的，它们便宜又欢快。我的意思是，基本上他的店是
the ancestor of the cheap and cheerful mass market shops that you have now, Uniqlo or whatever, or Primark, or the big kind of retailers that you have in Britain right now. His sort of pile them high, sell them cheap, very jolly, very brightly colored. And Carnaby Street, because it is run down, there's nothing going on there that's the place he identifies it's obviously very central what's happened to london so there's a whole london story here that we haven't really touched on at all which is that what is happening to london in this period is manufacturing is fleeing london so london which was a manufacturing city in a port city those things are dying all those people are moving out of the city center and means there's a
你现在拥有的那些便宜又欢快的大众市场商店的祖先，优衣库之类的，或者Primark，或者你现在在英国拥有的那些大型零售商。他那种堆得高高的、卖得便宜的风格，非常欢快，颜色非常鲜艳。而卡纳比街，因为它很破旧，那里没什么事发生，那是他确定的地方，它显然非常中心。伦敦发生了什么？所以这里有一个我们根本没怎么触及的伦敦故事，那就是在这个时期伦敦正在发生的事情是制造业正在逃离伦敦。所以伦敦，曾经是一个制造业城市和港口城市，那些东西正在消亡。所有那些人都在搬出市中心，这意味着有
lot of cheap office space, housing space, and so on. So younger people are moving in and that's where you get all the boutiques and stuff. And Carnaby Street is a classic example of that. So by 1967, John Stephen owns 10 boutiques in Carnaby Street alone. And because of the success of the Beatles and their worldwide marketing of swinging London, now, for the first time, you have tourists coming from overseas, also because of the availability of cheap air travel, tourists coming from overseas, and they want to go and buy a pair of Union Jack underpants from a terrible shop on Carnaby Street, as people do today, Tom.
大量的廉价办公空间、住房空间等等。所以年轻人正在搬进来，这就是你得到所有精品店之类东西的地方。卡纳比街就是一个典型的例子。所以到1967年，仅在卡纳比街，约翰·斯蒂芬就拥有10家精品店。由于披头士乐队的成功以及他们对摇摆伦敦的全球营销，现在，第一次，你有来自海外的游客，也因为廉价航空旅行的普及，游客从海外赶来，他们想去卡纳比街的一家糟糕商店买一条印有英国国旗的内裤，就像今天的人们所做的那样，汤姆。
Isn't it time that Christens London is swinging London? Time magazine, yes. Here's the funny thing. You know, most people at this point, so if you'd walk down Carnaby Street, most people it time that christians london are swinging london time magazine yes here's the funny thing you know most people at this point so if you'd walk down carnaby street most people obviously don't look tremendously cool right they're not wearing all these amazing clothes there's a wonderful story in the times the fashion editor of the times who was somebody called prudence glinn she was one of these sort of slightly forbidding women who are the gatekeepers of fashion actually make or break
难道不是《时代》杂志把伦敦称为“摇摆伦敦”吗？是的。有趣的事情在这里。你知道，此时大多数人，如果你走在卡纳比街，大多数人显然看起来并不特别酷，对吧？他们并没有穿所有这些惊人的衣服。在《泰晤士报》上有一个精彩的故事，《泰晤士报》的时尚编辑是一个叫普鲁登斯·格林的人，她是那种稍微有点令人敬畏的女性，她们是时尚的守门人，实际上决定了
people's reputations and careers she wrote a story story in August, 1966, the peak of the swinging London craze. She said, I was on the London underground and I looked around all the women on the tube and there were 17 of them. 12 of them were wearing cardigans. 10 of them were wearing navy blue, 13 were wearing sandals. Not one was wearing a miniskirt, not one is wearing a space man's outfit. None of them are dressed in the sort of... So actually, for most people, it has yet to really trickle down. But this is very Sandbrook. Right.
人们的声誉和职业生涯。她在1966年8月写了一个故事，当时正是摇摆伦敦热潮的巅峰。她说，我在伦敦地铁上，我环顾四周，车厢里有17名女性。其中12个穿着开衫。10个穿着海军蓝，13个穿着凉鞋。没有一个人穿迷你裙，没有一个人穿宇航员服装。她们中没有一个人穿着那种……所以实际上，对大多数人来说，它还没有真正渗透下来。但这非常桑德布鲁克。没错。
Very, very Sandbrook to basically dump on iconic moments or monuments to the 60s and say, well, most people aren't doing it. But it doesn't really matter, does it? Because it's the myth that matters. Because as you rightly say, Time magazine, just about three months earlier, run this very famous cover story. The title of it is You Can Walk Across It on the Grass. And they had basically, London, the swinging city. A year earlier, the Weekend Telegraph had done exactly the same.
非常非常桑德布鲁克，基本上就是抨击60年代的标志性时刻或纪念碑，说，好吧，大多数人并没有那样做。但这并不重要，不是吗？因为重要的是神话。因为正如你正确指出的那样，就在三个月前，《时代》杂志刊登了这篇非常著名的封面故事。标题是“你可以在草地上走过它”。他们基本上把伦敦称为摇摆之城。一年前，《周末电讯报》也做了完全一样的事情。
Periodicals in France, Italy, in Germany are doing exactly the same, saying, you know, London is the city. It is the cool place. Everybody is young. Everybody is full of fun. This is when the Kinks released Dedicated Follower of Fashion. Follower of Fashion, exactly. And that is a kind of a mockery of...
法国、意大利、德国的期刊都在做同样的事情，说，你知道，伦敦是这座城市。它是酷的地方。每个人都很年轻。每个人都充满乐趣。这就是奇想乐队发行《时尚的忠实追随者》的时候。时尚的追随者，没错。那是一种嘲讽……
It's mocking it because everybody knows it's a bit of a con. The happiest and most electric city in Europe, says the Spanish magazine Epoca. Great days, great days. So, of course, this is a sort of, in some ways, a ludicrous parody. But it's one in which so many people are invested and they believe in fashion like pop music. It's one of the two poles. One is, I mean, specifically is pop. It's sort of the Beatles and the imitators at this point because it's not really yet rock.
它在嘲讽，因为每个人都知道这有点骗局。西班牙杂志《Epoca》称它是欧洲最快乐、最令人兴奋的城市。伟大的日子，伟大的日子。所以，当然，这在某种程度上是一种荒谬的模仿。但这是许多人投入其中的一种，他们像对待流行音乐一样相信时尚。它是两个极点之一。一个是，我的意思是，具体来说是流行音乐。在这一点上，它是披头士乐队和模仿者，因为它还不是真正的摇滚。
And then the other is the fashion, the clothes, the mini skirts, the emphasis on youth. And Jonathan Aitken, you know, Jonathan Aitken, Tom, the guy who the trusty sword of truth and the shield of... Fair play. So he was telling... So people who don't know what we're talking about, he was a Conservative cabinet minister in the 1990s who fought a disastrous libel action. But he went out with Mrs. Thatcher's daughter, Carol, and made her cry. He did.
然后另一个是时尚，衣服，迷你裙，对年轻人的强调。还有乔纳森·艾特肯，你知道乔纳森·艾特肯，汤姆，那个拥有真理之剑和盾牌的家伙……公平地说。所以他当时正在告诉……所以不知道我们在说什么的人，他是1990年代的一位保守党内阁大臣，打了一场灾难性的诽谤官司。但他和撒切尔夫人的女儿卡罗尔约会，并让她哭了。他确实这么做了。
He did. A raffish Conservative MP. He ended up being imprisoned, didn't he, for perjury. Was it perjury? Yeah. In his failed libel trial against the Guardian. Very Oscar Wilde behaviour.
他确实这么做了。一位放荡不羁的保守党议员。他最终入狱了，不是吗，因为伪证罪。是伪证罪吗？是的。在他对《卫报》的失败诽谤审判中。非常奥斯卡·王尔德式的行为。
Very Oscar Wilde behaviour. But he, in the 60s, was a very cool young journalist and he wrote a book called The Young Meteors, which is actually, for those people who are interested in this period,
非常奥斯卡·王尔德式的行为。但在60年代，他是一位非常酷的年轻记者，他写了一本书叫《年轻的流星》，对于那些对这个时期感兴趣的人来说，
it is a tremendous read. It's a brilliant read. It's the best book on swinging London. He completely buys into this. He says, fashion has seized all the threads of the contemporary cults and woven them together in a strand that binds the entire younger generation with a new sense of identity and
这是一本极好的读物。这是一本精彩的读物。它是关于摇摆伦敦最好的书。他完全相信这一点。他说，时尚已经抓住了当代崇拜的所有线索，并将它们编织在一起，形成了一股束缚整个年轻一代的纽带，赋予了他们一种新的身份感和
vitality. And he says- He's a vicar now. He is. I know. He's found God. He found God in prison. Yeah.
活力。他说——他现在是个牧师。他是。我知道。他找到了上帝。他在监狱里找到了上帝。是的。
Man o' cloth. So that's 1966 that he publishes that. And now that we're in 1966, we should talk about the one person who was called the face of 66, who we haven't talked about at all and is probably, for some of our overseas listeners who know a bit about the 60s, they may be wondering why haven't we mentioned
神职人员。所以那是1966年他出版的那本书。现在我们到了1966年，我们应该谈谈那个被称为“66年的面孔”的人，我们根本没谈过她，对于我们一些了解60年代的海外听众来说，他们可能想知道为什么我们没有提到
the one female character who is more emblematic of all this than any other, and that is, of course, Twiggy. So are you a Twiggy fan, Tom? Not particularly. That is a shocking... I don't really have strong views on Twiggy. That's a shocking revelation. She's so famous that I'd never really stopped to think what her name actually meant. Oh, really? So her real name, you know what her real name is?
那个比任何其他人都更能代表这一切的女性角色，那当然就是崔姬。所以你是崔姬的粉丝吗，汤姆？不是特别。那是一个令人震惊的……我对崔姬没有强烈的看法。那是一个令人震惊的启示。她太出名了，以至于我从来没有真正停下来思考她的名字到底是什么意思。哦，真的吗？所以她的真名，你知道她的真名是什么吗？
Leslie Hornby. But would you have known that if you didn't have my notes in front of you? No, I wouldn't have known that. So she's from Neasden. And to give you to give you a i mean kneesden for our overseas sisters it's a synonymous i'm not dissing kneesden but in britain it's kind of synonymous with suburban banality isn't it because private eye the satirical magazine uses it as a sort of the tittering public school boys at private eye tom yeah you can't be dissing tittering public school boys on the rest is history That's the ultimate in self-flagellation. So her dad is a carpenter at the Elstree Film Studios.
莱斯利·霍恩比。但如果你面前没有我的笔记，你会知道吗？不，我不会知道。所以她来自尼斯登。为了给你一个——我的意思是，尼斯登对我们的海外姐妹来说，它是同义词，我不是在贬低尼斯登，但在英国，它有点像郊区平庸的代名词，不是吗？因为《私家侦探》，那本讽刺杂志，用它作为一种……《私家侦探》里那些咯咯笑的公立学校男孩，汤姆，是的，你不能在《历史就是如此》里贬低咯咯笑的公立学校男孩。那是自我鞭笞的极致。所以她的父亲是埃尔斯特里电影制片厂的一名木匠。
It's actually a sort of respectable working class, as people used to call it, aspirational household that she grows up in. She wrote a memoir called Twiggy on Twiggy or Twiggy by Twiggy in the late 60s, which I actually found incredibly interesting as a bit of social history, because she is an absolutely typical example of that sort of social type that we were talking about who drives this revolution. She's a teenager in the early 60s. She's obsessed with pop music, with telly, with dancing, with fashion. She works on Saturdays at the local hairdressers. She earns 30 shillings a week, and she spends almost all that on clothes. Her heroine, by the way, is Jean Shrimpton, victor of the Battle of Melbourne. She does her
这实际上是一个相当体面的工人阶级，正如人们过去所称的，有抱负的家庭，她在那里长大。她在60年代末写了一本回忆录叫《崔姬谈崔姬》或《崔姬由崔姬所写》，我发现它作为一点社会历史非常有趣，因为她是那种推动这场革命的社会类型的绝对典型例子。她在60年代初还是个十几岁的孩子。她痴迷于流行音乐、电视、跳舞、时尚。她周六在当地理发店工作。她每周赚30先令，几乎全部花在衣服上。顺便说一句，她的女英雄是“墨尔本战役”的胜利者吉恩·什林普顿。她用
face in the sort of the white and black makeup. What's remarkable about her is she's so androgynous. So she's tiny. Well, she's a twig. I mean, she's five foot five or five foot six. She weighs six and a half stone, shoe size four, dress size six. She weighs six and a half stone shoe size four dress size six she basically looks like a waif like an urchin and she starts going out with this immensely amusing person who knows her because his brother works in the barbers next to the hairdressing salon where she works he calls himself justin de ville nerve but do you know what his real name is no nigel davis oh so justin de ville nerve he's just a
那种白色和黑色的化妆品来化妆。她最引人注目的是她非常中性。所以她很瘦小。好吧，她是一根细枝。我的意思是，她五英尺五或五英尺六。她体重六英石半，鞋码四号，裙码六号。她体重六英石半，鞋码四号，裙码六号。她基本上看起来像个流浪儿，像个顽童。她开始和这个极其有趣的人约会，他认识她是因为他的兄弟在她工作的理发店旁边的理发店工作。他自称贾斯汀·德·维尔纳夫，但你知道他的真名是什么吗？不，奈杰尔·戴维斯。哦，所以贾斯汀·德·维尔纳夫，他只是一个
sort of a chancer really he starts going out with leslie as she's called and he says um i think you should try it as a model even though you're so skinny now most models so that is june shrimptons they are posh tom yeah they've been to the lucy clayton school of modeling yeah they've often been to private schools it's just a thing that you do if you're a kind of posh girl but the whole vibe of the mid-60s is classless it's classless leslie hornby has not been to any of these things she's not been to the the modeling school she is not posh but basically she manages to get a foot in the door at a sort of cheap down market magazine called the women's mirror and in the course of this sort of there's a complicated origin story but in the course of this photo shoot she goes and has a haircut in this salon and they give her
某种机会主义者，真的。他开始和莱斯利约会，正如她所称的那样，他说，嗯，我觉得你应该尝试做模特，尽管你这么瘦。现在大多数模特，也就是吉恩·什林普顿那种，她们是时髦的，汤姆。是的，她们上过露西·克莱顿模特学校。是的，她们经常上私立学校，如果你是一个时髦的女孩，这只是你做的一件事。但60年代中期的整个氛围是无阶级的，它是无阶级的。莱斯利·霍恩比没有上过任何这些学校，她没上过模特学校，她不时髦，但基本上她设法在一家叫《女性镜报》的廉价低端杂志上找到了机会。在这个过程中，有一个复杂的起源故事，但在这次照片拍摄过程中，她去了一家沙龙剪头发，他们给了她
this sort of um this cropped haircut all the stuff that we were talking about before about looking young with the big eyes and the pale face she has that already and especially with the cropped haircut this wave flight look she looks like an urchins from oliver twist she does a bit doesn't she yeah and the hairdressers put up photos of it because they're really struck by her appearance and a few days later the fashion editor of the daily express who's called deirdre mcshary she goes in she sees the photo says oh who's that i want to get in touch with her and so on the 23rd of february 1966 in the middle of the daily Express kind of middle spread there's a massive photograph of Leslie Hornby's face and the headline says Twiggy the Cockney kid and have they made up
这种短发，我们之前谈到的所有关于大眼睛和苍白脸庞看起来年轻的东西，她已经有了，尤其是加上短发，这种流浪儿般的造型，她看起来像《雾都孤儿》里的顽童。她确实有点像，不是吗？是的，理发师贴出了她的照片，因为他们被她的外表深深打动了。几天后，《每日快报》的时尚编辑，叫迪尔德丽·麦克沙里，她进去了，看到了照片，说，哦，那是谁？我想和她取得联系，等等。1966年2月23日，在《每日快报》的中间跨页上，有一张莱斯利·霍恩比脸部的巨大照片，标题写着“崔姬，那个伦敦小子”，他们编造了
the name Twiggy no so her friends or Justin de Villeneuve aka Nigel Davis called her that as a joke but people love the name they think oh what a brilliant name the headline says the cockney kid with the face to launch a thousand shapes and she's going to be the face of 66 the calm appraisal of a child or a martian a rare strange creature tranquil composed almost bloodless yeah one half orphan of the storm the other purely aesthetic so people as they were doing with the beatles and stuff i mean obviously older people who are trying to look cool go completely bonkers and write these ridiculously pretentious analyses of her appeal. How do older women who can't emulate this kind of waif-like look, I mean, how are they feeling about the fact that this is now being projected as the fashion that everyone should be following?
“崔姬”这个名字吗？不，所以她的朋友或贾斯汀·德·维尔纳夫（又名奈杰尔·戴维斯）开玩笑地叫她那个名字，但人们喜欢这个名字，他们想，哦，多么棒的名字。标题说“那个拥有启动一千种造型面孔的伦敦小子”，她将成为66年的面孔。对一个孩子或火星人的冷静评估，一个罕见的奇怪生物，平静、沉着，几乎没有血色。是的，一半是风暴孤儿，另一半纯粹是审美。所以人们就像他们对待披头士乐队一样，我的意思是，显然那些试图看起来很酷的老年人完全疯了，写了这些极其自命不凡的关于她吸引力的分析。那些无法模仿这种流浪儿造型的老年女性，我的意思是，她们对这现在被投射为每个人都应该追随的时尚有什么感觉？
They're probably quite grumpy about it. So there are lots of women who will say, of the 60s, I didn't have the shape for the 60s, as there had been in the 20s, of course, with flappers. There are lots of women who say all these new fashions actually make absolutely no allowance for how real women look. Because Twiggy is so slight and so androgynous that obviously most women don't look like her at all. However, there is this kind of weird rejection of womanhood and especially, I would say, motherhood in the late 60s, which is a rejection of the kind of housewife ethos of the 1950s. And is that influenced by the coming of the pill, do you think? No, because the pill is not available to unmarried women until 1970. Right.
她们可能对此相当暴躁。所以有很多女性会说，关于60年代，我没有60年代的身材，当然，20年代的飞来波女郎也是如此。有很多女性说所有这些新时尚实际上根本没有考虑真实女性的样子。因为崔姬太瘦小且太中性了，显然大多数女性根本不像她。然而，60年代末有一种对女性气质，尤其是，我会说，母性的奇怪排斥，这是对1950年代家庭主妇精神的一种排斥。你认为这受到避孕药到来的影响吗？不，因为避孕药直到1970年才对未婚女性开放。没错。
But there is a sort of sense of sexual availability, I suppose, of a loosening of moral attitudes. Obviously, more women in education than ever, women entering the workforce in higher numbers. But also that becoming a parent is very ungroovy. Very ungroovy. The two things that are actually very ungroovy in the 60s are A, becoming a parent, and B, refusing to have sex with somebody. So this is the whole thing that people would now say. Some people, by the way, did say at the time that the sexual revolution is very one way that the sexual dynamic of the late 1960s is actually quite predatory and quite unpleasant. I mean, you read the 60s manifestos written by countercultural people between 1965 and 1970.
但有一种性可获得性的感觉，我想，道德态度的放松。显然，接受教育的女性比以往任何时候都多，进入劳动力的女性数量也在增加。但也有一种成为父母是非常不时髦的感觉。非常不时髦。在60年代，两件非常不时髦的事情是：A，成为父母；B，拒绝与某人发生性关系。所以这就是人们现在会说的一切。顺便说一句，当时有些人确实说性革命是非常单向的，60年代末的性动力实际上相当掠夺性且相当令人不快。我的意思是，你读读1965年到1970年间由反文化人士撰写的60年代宣言。
I mean, there's some pretty, yeah, I mean, sometimes we use the word pungent on this podcast to describe stuff we don't approve of. I think there's actually some pretty downright shocking and horrible stuff in those memoirs about young girls, all of this kind of thing. I mean, even actually The Guardian, 1965, the point about very short skirts, white lace stockings and pantomime boots is that they separate the girls from the women. They say, I am young. I'm different, I am special. This sort of emphasis on being a young girl is a really central element of 60s fashion. Mary Quant, I grew up not wanting to grow up. Growing up seemed terrible. It meant having candy floss hair, stiletto heels, girdles,
我的意思是，有一些相当……是的，我的意思是，有时我们在播客中使用“刺鼻”这个词来描述我们不赞成的东西。我认为在那些关于年轻女孩的回忆录中，确实有一些相当令人震惊和可怕的东西。我的意思是，甚至《卫报》1965年也提到，非常短的裙子、白色蕾丝长袜和哑剧靴的意义在于它们将女孩与女性区分开来。她们说，我很年轻。我很特别。这种对成为年轻女孩的强调是60年代时尚的一个核心元素。玛丽·匡特，我长大后不想长大。长大看起来太可怕了。这意味着拥有棉花糖般的头发、细高跟鞋、束腰，
and great boobs. And all this sort of stuff. I mean, here's this, Mary Quant again. Now, this is unbelievable, Tom. There was a time when every girl under 20 yearned to look like an experienced, sophisticated 30. She writes this in 1966. All this is in reverse with a vengeance now. Suddenly, every girl with a hope of getting away with it is aiming to look not only under the voting age, but under the age of consent. And this sort of stuff about looking under the age of consent is everywhere. I mean, Mary Quant delights in this. She says, this is great. You're saying at the same time, because in the same thing, she says, the girl of today is standing there defiantly with her legs apart saying, I'm very sexy. I enjoy sex. I feel provocative,
和巨大的胸部。所有这些东西。我的意思是，这是玛丽·匡特。现在，这令人难以置信，汤姆。曾经有一段时间，每个20岁以下的女孩都渴望看起来像一个经验丰富、成熟的30岁女性。她在1966年写道。现在这一切都彻底反转了。突然间，每个有希望蒙混过关的女孩的目标不仅是看起来未到投票年龄，而且是未到同意年龄。这种关于看起来未到同意年龄的东西随处可见。我的意思是，玛丽·匡特对此感到高兴。她说，这太棒了。你同时在说，因为在同一件事中，她说，今天的女孩正挑衅地站在那里，双腿分开，说，我很性感。我享受性。我觉得自己很有挑逗性，
but you're going to have to job to get me. I can't be bought, but if I want you, I'll have you. And this sort of emphasis on sexual availability and extreme youth to a 21st century reader is pretty, you know... But there's, I guess it's not actually a paradox perhaps, but one of the big kind of gear shifts in the 60s is between 66 and 67. And in 67, even as girls are still being encouraged to look very young, suddenly boys are growing enormous beards and hair sprouting everywhere. They are. And kind of becoming hyper-masculine. That is a very big tonal shift. And just before we come onto that, one last point about the girls. Some people may think I am being too censorious, that the Cromwellian
但你得努力才能得到我。我不能被买通，但如果我想要你，我会得到你。这种对性可获得性和极端年轻的强调，对21世纪的读者来说是相当……但我猜这也许不是一个悖论，但60年代最大的转变之一是在66年到67年之间。而在67年，即使女孩们仍然被鼓励看起来非常年轻，突然间男孩们开始留起巨大的胡子，头发到处乱长。他们确实如此。并且变得超级阳刚。这是一个非常大的基调转变。在我们谈到这一点之前，关于女孩的最后一点。有些人可能认为我太爱指责了，认为《历史就是如此》的克伦威尔式
presenter of the rest of history is frowning on people's fun. But you read this. This is a 1965, an American reporter. He says, the great thing about England is that young English girls take to sex as if it's candy and it's delicious. I mean, no one would write that now. And actually, I'm not back projecting because even at the time, there were people who said this is not right.
主持人正在对人们的乐趣皱眉头。但你读读这个。这是一个1965年的美国记者。他说，英国最棒的地方在于年轻的英国女孩把性当作糖果一样对待，而且它很美味。我的意思是，现在没人会那样写了。而且实际上，我并没有进行反向投射，因为即使在当时，也有人说这是不对的。
And actually, the most famous one of those is Germaine Greer. So taking us back to Australia, Tom. Yeah. So this is the female eunuch. The female eunuch. At the end of the 1960s, I think it's 1970, the female eunuch is partly about the image of the dolly bird that you see everywhere in the 1960s. And she says, her dominion must not be thought to entail the rule of women, for she is
而且实际上，其中最著名的是杰曼·格里尔。所以带我们回到澳大利亚，汤姆。是的。这就是《女性太监》。《女性太监》。在60年代末，我想是1970年，《女性太监》部分是关于你在60年代随处可见的时髦女郎形象。她说，她的统治不应被认为意味着女性的统治，因为她是
not a woman. She is a doll, weeping, pouting, or smiling, running or reclining. She is a doll. She is an idol formed of the concatenation of lines and masses, signifying the lineaments of satisfied impotence. She is, in other words, a female eunuch. And I think now, when you look back at that sort of the image of womanhood that is presented in the mid to late 60s, it looks to our eyes, I mean, at the time celebrated as liberated and exciting, but to our eyes, I think it looks, don't you think, pretty exploitative and a bit distasteful? I think we should take a break here. And when we come back the lord protector of the rest is history the man who wants to ban the 60s can cast his anti-fun gaze over a new figure in the cityscape of swinging london the
她不是女人。她是一个玩偶，哭泣、撅嘴或微笑，奔跑或躺卧。她是一个玩偶。她是一个由线条和块面组合而成的偶像，象征着一种满足的无能。换句话说，她是一个女性太监。我想现在回看60年代中后期呈现的那种女性形象，在当时被誉为解放和令人兴奋，但在我们看来，你不觉得吗，这看起来相当具有剥削性，甚至有点令人反感？我想我们应该在这里休息一下。当我们回来时，这位“其余皆是历史”的守护者，那个想要禁止60年代的人，将用他那反娱乐的目光审视摇摆伦敦城市景观中的一个新人物——
hippie we'll see you in a few minutes i'm marina hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Suddenly, happiness is flower-shaped. The in-things are Indian jackets and dresses, kimonos, Victorian dresses,
嬉皮士。几分钟后见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《其余皆是娱乐》。这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和优先购买现场票的权益，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。就是 therestisentertainment.com。突然间，幸福变成了花朵的形状。流行的东西是印度夹克和连衣裙、和服、维多利亚时代的裙子，
elaborately patterned, beaded, and flowing 20s and 30s dresses, bell-bottom trousers, and brocade waistcoats. Plus of course, those beads, bells and flowers. That was the daily sketch in July, 1967, the summer of love, the summer of Sergeant Pepper. All you need is love. And Dominic, 67 is a real kind of gear shift, isn't it? It is. I guess the female look of the sixties is miniskirts, and we've been talking about them.
图案繁复、串珠且飘逸的20年代和30年代裙装、喇叭裤和锦缎背心。当然，还有那些珠子、铃铛和花朵。那是1967年7月的每日素描，爱之夏，佩珀中士之夏。你所需要的只是爱。多米尼克，67年确实是一个转折点，不是吗？确实是。我想60年代的女性造型是迷你裙，我们一直在谈论它们。
But the male look probably paradigmatically is a hippie, beard, John Lennon glasses, kind of caftans. Only from this point onwards, Tom. Yeah. So one of the things I really love about social and cultural history, lots of people don't do it enough, I think, is nailing down the narrative. So at what point do people start having beards? People are not wearing beads and bangles in 1965, but they are in 1968. So when does that change? So Sgt. Pepper, the Beatles are wearing moustaches, but not beards. Exactly. And I think that is a huge change, by the way. So the Beatles, we've mentioned them a few times in these episodes. They're obviously a massive influence in all this because they are the chief
但男性的造型可能典型的就是嬉皮士，留着胡子，戴着约翰·列侬式的眼镜，穿着那种长袍。只有从这一点开始，汤姆。是的。所以我非常喜欢社会和文化历史的一点是——很多人做得不够——那就是确定叙事。那么人们是从什么时候开始留胡子的呢？人们在1965年不戴珠子和手镯，但他们在1968年戴了。那么这种变化是什么时候发生的呢？所以《佩珀中士》，披头士乐队留着小胡子，但没有留大胡子。没错。而且我认为这是一个巨大的变化。所以披头士乐队，我们在这些剧集中提到过他们几次。他们显然对这一切有着巨大的影响，因为他们是
exporters of a British look abroad. But so Sergeant Pepper, they are working on it at the end, by the end of 1966, the beginning of 1967. So at that point, when the kind of the Avengers, Dolly Bird,
英国造型向海外的主要输出者。但《佩珀中士》，他们在1966年底、1967年初创作它。所以在那时，当那种“复仇者”、多莉鸟（Dolly Bird）、
Jean Shrimpton, Twiggy look is at its height, the kind of op art, close of the Future, all that stuff. They're going Victorian. And they're going Victorian. So that is one of the remarkable things about the Beatles is they're always, you know, six months to two years ahead of everybody else. The dominant motif of Sgt. Pepper's Lonely Hearts Club band, which comes out that June, June 67, is the kind of late Victorian Edwardian musical. And so, again, we talked about Teddy Boys, didn't we, in the previous episode?
简·施林普顿、崔姬的造型处于巅峰时，那种欧普艺术、未来主义的服装，所有这些东西。他们转向了维多利亚风格。他们转向了维多利亚风格。所以披头士乐队最了不起的事情之一就是他们总是比其他人领先六个月到两年。67年6月发行的《佩珀中士孤独之心俱乐部乐队》的主导主题是那种维多利亚晚期到爱德华时代的音乐剧。所以，我们上一集谈到了泰迪男孩，不是吗？
Yeah. That there's obviously a kind of abiding appeal. There is. And a fascination with Victoriana, I think it's fair to say. So there had been massive exhibitions on Alphonse Mucha and Aubrey Beardsley in 1963 and 1966. People in the 60s. For the first time, really, they're taking the late Victorians seriously rather than rejecting them.
是的。显然有一种持久的吸引力。确实有。而且对维多利亚时代有一种迷恋，我认为这样说是公平的。所以1963年和1966年举办了关于阿尔丰斯·穆夏和奥布里·比亚兹莱的大型展览。60年代的人们。他们第一次真正认真对待维多利亚晚期的人，而不是拒绝他们。
So the Beatles' moustaches, are they Victorian, do you think, rather than being influenced by what people are growing in California? Yeah, because the Beatles are growing there first, by the way. The Beatles are, I would argue, I mean, I'm not saying they're the first people
那么披头士的小胡子，你认为它们是维多利亚风格的，而不是受到加州人们留胡子的影响吗？是的，因为顺便说一下，披头士是先在那里留的。披头士是，我会争辩说，我的意思是，我并不是说他们是人类历史上第一个
in human history to have had moustaches. Well, no, because the British elites, British military men in the late Victorian period, paradigmatically have moustaches. They are. And it's part of the military uniform, actually, isn't it? Because the Beatles are wearing uniforms on the cover of Sgt. Pepper. And uniforms become very fashionable at about that point, 1967. The most famous shop where you can buy them is I Was
留小胡子的人。嗯，不，因为英国精英，维多利亚晚期的英国军人，典型地都有小胡子。他们确实有。而且这实际上是军装的一部分，不是吗？因为披头士在《佩珀中士》的封面上穿着制服。而制服在1967年左右变得非常时髦。你可以买到它们的最著名的商店是“我曾是
Lord Kitchener's Valet, or I Was Lord Kitchener's Valet, which you would go to on the Portobello Road. And there you would buy, it's an ironic imperial shop, isn't it? Right, because Lord Kitchener is the figure on the recruiting poster at the beginning of the First World War. Your country needs you, and one of the paradigmatic imperial heroes. Now I think none of this would have been possible if the British Empire had not by this point definitively been dissolved. So actually when people even today say, oh
基奇纳勋爵的男仆”，或者“我曾是基奇纳勋爵的男仆”，你会去波托贝洛路买。在那里你会买到，这是一家讽刺帝国主义的商店，不是吗？对，因为基奇纳勋爵是第一次世界大战初期征兵海报上的人物。“国家需要你”，是典型的帝国英雄之一。现在我认为，如果大英帝国到那时还没有彻底解体，这一切都不可能实现。所以实际上，即使在今天，当人们说“哦，
Britain hasn't come to terms with the loss of empire, I think actually Britain has come to terms with it perfectly well by this point. Because by this point they're already making a great joke of it. Yeah, they're ironising it. It's very funny. They think it's a tremendous laugh to have imperial shops and to dress up in imperial, to look like General Gordon, basically. Okay, but a question.
英国还没有接受帝国丧失的事实”时，我认为实际上英国到那时已经完全接受了。因为到那时他们已经在拿它开玩笑了。是的，他们在讽刺它。这非常有趣。他们认为拥有帝国商店并打扮成帝国风格，基本上看起来像戈登将军，是一种巨大的笑话。好吧，但有一个问题。
So what the British do during the imperial period is go to India, where they go around with moustaches and swagger sticks and kind of tell people what to do. Whereas the Beatles famously go to India and they dress in Indian clothes and they get told what to do by the Maharishi. Lots of them don't like it. Well, Ringo Starr, of course, travels Tom with his own baked beans because he doesn't trust the Indian food. Yeah. So the interest in dressing like in Indian fashions, is there any link to the kind of repudiation of the age of the Raj there, do you think, or not? Would
所以英国人在帝国时期所做的是去印度，他们留着小胡子，拿着指挥棒，告诉人们该做什么。而披头士著名地去了印度，他们穿着印度服装，被玛哈礼希告知该做什么。他们中很多人不喜欢。嗯，林戈·斯塔尔当然带着他自己的烤豆旅行，汤姆，因为他不相信印度食物。是的。所以对穿着印度时尚的兴趣，你认为这与对拉吉时代的否定有任何联系吗？还是
that be over-intellectualizing it? I think it's more that there's always been a strain of Orientalism in British popular culture that stretches right back to the Victorian period, maybe even beyond. But that's bread of the empire, isn't it? It's bread of the empire. And it's still there. I mean, why India? Why sitars? Why the Maharishi? Because in a way- It's familiar to British people. It's familiar. They're prepped for it. It seems the logic, it seems an understandable thing to do
那会是过度解读？我认为更多的是英国流行文化中一直存在一种东方主义，可以追溯到维多利亚时代，甚至可能更早。但那是帝国的面包，不是吗？那是帝国的面包。而且它仍然存在。我的意思是，为什么是印度？为什么是西塔琴？为什么是玛哈礼希？因为在某种程度上——这对英国人来说很熟悉。很熟悉。他们对此有准备。这看起来逻辑上是合理的，看起来是一件可以理解的事情，
that people go to India to seek enlightenment because of course people have been doing that for rich bohemian people. So do Indian fashions have the same impact outside Britain or is it a distinctively British fashion, do you think? I think when it goes to California and then to America more widely, I would say it's a general kind of ethnic look, isn't it? There's a very much an ethnic, what people, I mean, that's the term that people would have used in the late 1960s, early 1970s, rugs, bangles, jostics, incense.
人们去印度寻求启蒙，因为当然，富有的波西米亚人一直在这样做。那么印度时尚在英国之外有同样的影响吗，还是你认为这是一种独特的英国时尚？我认为当它传到加州，然后更广泛地传到美国时，我会说这是一种普遍的民族风，不是吗？这非常有民族感，我的意思是，那是60年代末、70年代初人们会使用的术语，地毯、手镯、线香、熏香。
Statues of Hindu gods. Eastern religions. Now, obviously the United States at that point doesn't have the same kind of relationship with India specifically as Britain does. So in the US, in California,
印度教神像。东方宗教。现在，显然美国在那个时候与印度的关系与英国不同。所以在美国，在加州，
it might be mixed up with Native American stuff and those kinds of things. But yeah, there's a fascination with the East that comes in in the late 60s.
它可能与美洲原住民的东西和那些类似的东西混在一起。但确实，60年代末出现了一种对东方的迷恋。
I mean, you can connect this, I think, with a general reaction against industrial modernity that is very pronounced in the late 60s. That's part of the hippie thing. So hence the flowers.
我的意思是，我认为你可以将此与60年代末非常明显的对工业现代性的普遍反应联系起来。这是嬉皮士运动的一部分。所以才有了花朵。
The flowers. Now, everyone would have seen probably photos of people putting flowers, anti-Vietnam War protesters putting flowers into the rifles of National Guardsmen. And I think Vietnam is part of this, actually. Vietnam is- But that's American, isn't it? So is there a sense as you move into, say, into 1968, that London's fashion crown is slipping and passing to peaceniks in America? I think definitely. So by the beginning of 1968, the elements of this new look are already there. The bell-bottom trousers, the flare trousers. By the way, that's coming out of the uniform thing,
花朵。现在，每个人可能都看过人们把花朵，反越战抗议者把花朵放进国民警卫队的步枪里的照片。我认为越南战争实际上也是其中的一部分。越南是——但那是美国的，不是吗？所以当你进入，比如说，1968年时，是否有一种感觉，伦敦的时尚桂冠正在滑落，并传给了美国的和平主义者？我认为绝对是。所以到1968年初，这种新造型的元素已经存在了。喇叭裤，喇叭裤。顺便说一下，那是从制服演变而来的，
the flares. Right. And that takes us back to the Regency period where the influence of the dress of the Royal Navy is very influential
喇叭裤。对。这把我们带回了摄政时期，当时皇家海军的服装对英国绅士的造型演变非常有影响力。
on the look of the English gentleman as it evolves. And indeed, to our Trafalgar podcast, Tom, about the fascination of the Royal Navy and the, you know,
确实，回到我们的特拉法加播客，汤姆，关于对皇家海军的迷恋，以及，你知道，
who would have thought only the rest is history can link from the fashions of 1968 to a three-part series about Trafalgar, which I heartily commend to the listeners. Because you had your flared trousers, it made it easier to roll up your trouser legs when you were working on deck. People start wearing the flared trousers, the beards, which look like imperial heroes. So why are they wearing beards? Is that just kind of logical, except if you've got a moustache, you might as well grow a beard?
谁会想到只有《其余皆是历史》能把1968年的时尚与关于特拉法加的三集系列节目联系起来，我衷心向听众推荐。因为你有喇叭裤，当你在甲板上工作时，卷起裤腿更容易。人们开始穿喇叭裤，留胡子，看起来像帝国英雄。那么他们为什么要留胡子呢？这只是逻辑上的吗，除了如果你有小胡子，你不如留个大胡子？
I think so. Because that's going beyond, obviously, a Victorian look. There is an argument by some historians of fashion and sort of sociologists and things that people start wearing the beards because as men's fashion is becoming more feminized, so they're wearing lacy shirts, flowery scarves, ridiculous, you know, Mick Jagger circa 1968 is wearing like a blouse he's wearing a dress isn't exactly all that stuff at the same time you have a beard because it's saying i'm still very much a man's man even though i'm wearing a dress and you know i've got i love flowers although conchita would not agree with that conchita verst the eurovision champion yes those are dark waters tom then which which I don't want to... Let's row back from those.
我想是这样。因为这显然超越了维多利亚风格。一些时尚历史学家和社会学家认为，人们开始留胡子是因为随着男装变得更加女性化，他们穿着蕾丝衬衫、花哨的围巾，荒谬的，你知道，1968年左右的米克·贾格尔穿着像衬衫一样的东西，他穿着裙子，完全是那样，同时你留着胡子，因为这在说“我仍然是一个十足的男子汉，尽管我穿着裙子，而且你知道，我喜欢花朵”，尽管孔奇塔不会同意这一点，孔奇塔·沃斯特，欧洲歌唱大赛冠军。是的，那是浑水，汤姆，我不想……让我们从那些话题中划回来。
So the idea of hippie, the word comes from hip, does it? Hip, hipster. So a black American word, African American word, then used by people like Norman Mailer to talk about white Americans copying black culture. So at that point, people are talking about hipsters and then that evolves into about 19 so it's interesting in 1965 66 american teenagers are copying british slang they're saying things are groovy you know gear gear yeah all that fab all that sort of stuff and actually even in
所以嬉皮士这个词，来自“hip”，是吗？Hip，hipster（时髦的人）。所以是一个黑人美国词汇，非裔美国人词汇，然后被诺曼·梅勒这样的人用来谈论模仿黑人文化的白人美国人。所以在那时，人们在谈论时髦人士，然后这演变成大约19——所以有趣的是，1965、66年，美国青少年在模仿英国俚语，他们说事情很“groovy”（时髦），你知道“gear”（棒极了），“fab”（绝妙），所有那种东西，实际上即使在
provincial american cities des moines iowa or, there will be shops called the Carnaby Store, the Soho Emporium, you know, I was General Gordon's Batman or whatever, you know, there'll be that. But by 1967, 68, that's no longer cool. And actually, the music, the British music is no longer as cool as it was actually you can judge that from the chart presence it's the doors the Grateful Dead
美国省会城市，得梅因，爱荷华州，会有叫“卡纳比商店”、“苏活区商场”的店，你知道，“我曾是戈登将军的勤务兵”之类的，你知道，会有那种东西。但到了1967、68年，那不再酷了。实际上，音乐，英国音乐不再像以前那么酷了，实际上你可以从排行榜表现中判断出来，是“大门乐队”、“感恩而死乐队”，
it's a much more druggie much more Californian sound actually California and San Francisco and LA have recaptured the sense of music more momentum
这是一种更迷幻、更加州的声音，实际上加州、旧金山和洛杉矶已经重新夺回了音乐的势头。
but the language the fashion that is much more being driven from California and the truth of the matter is Carnaby Street is now a massive tourist trap it's always been a bit of a tourist trap so it's very uncool Language, the fashion, that is much more being driven from California. And the truth of the matter is, Carnaby Street is now a massive tourist trap.
但语言、时尚，更多地是由加州驱动的。事实是，卡纳比街现在是一个巨大的旅游陷阱，它一直有点像旅游陷阱，所以它非常不酷。语言，时尚，更多地是由加州驱动的。事实是，卡纳比街现在是一个巨大的旅游陷阱。
It's always been a bit of a tourist trap. So it's very uncool. I mean, it's the uncoolest place in the world. It is. And, you know, going back to the origins of all this, Mary Quant, she opened her boutique bazaar in 1955. By 1968, who cares about 1955? I mean, it might as well have happened in the 13th century,
它一直有点像旅游陷阱。所以它非常不酷。我的意思是，它是世界上最不酷的地方。确实是。而且，你知道，回到这一切的起源，玛丽·匡特，她在1955年开了她的精品店。到了1968年，谁还在乎1955年？我的意思是，对年轻人来说，那可能发生在13世纪，
as far as youngsters. Because the people who are the shoppers now who are 18, they were five when she opened her boutique. So what do they care about that look? But also there's a sense, I mean, to live through the 60s is to feel that you're kind of running up a down escalator in terms of keeping up with fashion, I imagine. I mean, it's changing at such a speed. Yes. And so obviously. Yeah.
因为现在18岁的购物者，她开店时他们才五岁。所以他们怎么会在乎那种造型呢？但也有这种感觉，我的意思是，经历60年代就是感觉你在逆着自动扶梯奔跑，为了跟上时尚，我想象。我的意思是，它变化的速度太快了。是的。所以显然。是的。
But also there's a tonal shift. It's less optimistic, I think, I mean, it's changing at such a speed. Yes. And so obviously. Yeah. But also there's a tonal shift. It's less optimistic. I think the late sixties, it's more conflicted. The economy is beginning to slow down. And actually, as you say, you're rushing to keep up with fashion. But one of the things we often forget is that even in this period, if we talk about a long 1960s, there were different generational cohorts. So if you're 18 in 1968, 69, what people were buying in 1963, 64 just strikes you as ludicrously antiquated, laughable. You're not going to wear a PVC miniskirt in 1969 if you're very cool. I mean, obviously the truth of the matter is at any given moment, Tom, most people aren't very cool. So I wrote about this when I put White Heat
但也有基调的转变。我认为它不那么乐观，我的意思是，它变化的速度太快了。是的。所以显然。是的。但也有基调的转变。它不那么乐观。我认为60年代末，它更矛盾。经济开始放缓。而且正如你所说，你在匆忙跟上时尚。但我们经常忘记的一件事是，即使在这个时期，如果我们谈论一个漫长的60年代，也有不同的代际群体。所以如果你在1968、69年是18岁，人们在1963、64年买的东西只会让你觉得荒谬地过时、可笑。如果你很酷，你不会在1969年穿PVC迷你裙。我的意思是，显然事实是，在任何特定时刻，汤姆，大多数人都不太酷。所以我写过这个，当我写《白热》时，
and ITV made a drama called White Heat about people living through the 60s. And basically, because I had the title, they felt, it was actually
ITV制作了一部关于经历60年代的人们的电视剧叫《白热》。基本上，因为我有这个标题，他们觉得，这实际上是
a remarkable instance, probably the only instance in history of a TV studio feeling honor bound. That's unheard of. To recompense me for the fact
历史上一个非凡的例子，可能是唯一一个电视工作室感到有义务——这闻所未闻——补偿我，因为他们偷了我的标题。交易是他们说，好吧，你可以担任该系列的顾问，所以我去参加了这个会议，他们正在描述，你知道，它将设定在1966年，每个人都会穿着，你知道，宇航员的衣服，我说，他们都说，你觉得怎么样，我说，好吧，显然没人会想要那些衣服，它们看起来真的很无聊，而且它们看起来像人们真实的样子。他们不想听那个。
they had stolen my title. And the deal was they said well you can be the consultant to the series so i went along to this meeting and they were describing you know it's going to be set in 1966 everyone's going to be wearing you know astronauts clothes and i said and they said they all said what do you think and i said well obviously nobody would want those clothes they all look really boring and they all looked like people really looked. They didn't want to hear that.
那是最后一次邀请我参加的会议。一桶冷水。他们说，人们会听什么？我说，哦，可能是《音乐之声》。当然你会这么说。
That was the last meeting I was ever invited to. A sand bucket of cold water. They said, what would people be listening to? I said, oh, probably the sound of music. Of course you did.
当然。那是你的全部套路。确实是。这就是你做的。我不会把它描述为套路，而是一种深刻的洞察。一种好到让你不断回归的洞察。
Of course. That's your whole shtick. It is. That's what you do. I would describe it as a shtick so much as a penetrating insight. An insight so good that you keep returning to it.
我不断回归它，即使当电视公司乞求我远离时。好吧，所以这一切都很悲伤，伦敦度过了它的黄金时代。它很摇摆，很时髦，很棒。现在60年代结束了，他们在伍尔沃斯百货卖嬉皮假发。是的，所以难以置信的是，你可以买到，
That I keep returning to it, even when TV companies are begging me to stay away. Okay, so this is all rather sad then, that London had its time in the sun. It was swinging, it was groovy, it was gear. And now the 60s are ending and they're selling hippie wigs in Woolworths. Yeah, so unbelievably, you could buy,
我喜欢这个细节。它在哪里？我一定是在杂志或什么地方找到的。一个广告。用这些奇妙的新狂欢装扮来制造场景。你可以买到他们所谓的假鬓角，以及保罗·怀特制作公司制作的假胡子。哇。
I love this detail. Where is it? I must have found this in a magazine or something. An advert. Make the scene with these fantastic new raves. You can buy false side pieces, as they call them, and a false moustache made by Paul White Productions. Wow.
所以威斯纳尔和我不是在开玩笑。这就是重点，汤姆。口号说，正如电视上看到的那样。谁在电视上戴着它们？它说，这些爱德华风格的鬓角非常逼真，几乎无法察觉，可以反复使用。
So Withnell and I weren't joking. And here's the thing, Tom. The slogan says, as seen on TV. Who's wearing them on TV? It says, these Edwardian style sideburns are so realistic they're almost undetectable and can be used time and time again.
请寄一小撮你的头发进行颜色匹配。你的色调将尽可能匹配，那个古老的骗局，然后有一个注释说不包括胶水，所有这些人走来走去，胡子是用胶水粘的，这很悲伤，在那一点上，你知道，早期精品店的精神已经远去了，梦想结束了，没错，所以60年代末出现了一种疯狂精品店的繁荣，所以“奶奶去旅行”，那是披头士拥有的，不是吗？苹果商店是
Please send a small cutting of your hair for colour and matching. Your shade will be matched as near as possible that old scammy and then there's a note that says glue not included all these people walking around with with mustaches glued it's very sad at that point you know that the the spirit of the early boutiques is a long way away the dream is over exactly so there's a sort of efflorescence of these mad boutiques in the late 60s so granny takes a trip that's the kind of beatles have one don't they the apple store is
一种，我的意思是，绝望的人们只是带着不起作用的疯狂小玩意跑来跑去，最著名的一家，总是被当作关于60年代时尚发生了什么的寓言，是Biba。你听说过Biba，显然，汤姆。是的，我听说过。这是一个非凡的、非凡的故事。它由一个叫芭芭拉·胡拉尼基的人经营。她出生于波兰父母。她的父亲在1940年代被斯特恩帮杀害。我告诉你还有谁。我们根本没谈过的人，维达尔·沙宣，理发师。所以他做了玛丽·匡特的头发，那个非常著名的波波头。他在1940年代和1948年的阿拉伯-以色列战争中战斗过。他曾是伦敦一个叫“43小组”的反法西斯小队的一员，他们到处殴打英国反犹太法西斯分子。
a kind of i mean hopeless people just running off with mad gizmos that don't work and things and the most famous one of these so the one that is, always taken as the parable about what happens to 60s fashion is Bieber. You've heard of Bieber, obviously, Tom. Yeah, I have. It's a remarkable, remarkable story. So it's run by somebody called Barbara Hulonicki. She was born to Polish parents. Her father was killed by the Stern Gang in the 1940s. I'll tell you who else. Somebody we haven't talked about at all, Vidal Sassoon, the hairdresser. So he did kind of Mary Quant's hair in this very famous bob. He fought in the Arab-Israeli war in the 1940s and 1948. And he had been part of an anti-fascist sort of squad in London called the 43 Group, who went around beating up British anti-Semitic fascists.
天哪。我完全不知道。无论如何，这是从Biba引出的。所以芭芭拉·胡拉尼基，她在布莱顿艺术学院学习。她卖那种非常早期的60年代格子裙。实际上，她真的走在潮流前面，因为她能看到，我想是因为她认识到了这种对维多利亚风格等的潜在胃口。她在1964年在肯辛顿开了她的店Biba。当时，人们说，哦，它看起来像一个东方集市。
Goodness. I had no idea. Anyway, this is a segue from Bieber. So Barbara Huluniki, she'd studied at Brighton Art College. She sold kind of very early 60s gingham dresses. And actually, she's really ahead of the curve because she can see, I suppose because she recognizes this latent appetite for Victoriana and stuff. She opens Biba, her shop, in 1964 in Kensington. And at the time, people say, oh, it looks like an Eastern souk.
它充满了扎染的东西和栗色的围巾，颜色非常深。所以它看起来与任何其他东西完全不同。她在这一切上都遥遥领先。所以Biba在那个程度上非常酷。换句话说，它提前三四年销售1968年的时尚。到60年代末，它是伦敦所有服装店中最时髦、最著名的，所以它吸引了朱莉·克里斯蒂、碧姬·芭铎、玛丽安·菲斯福尔这样的名人，她们来那里购物，它非常便宜，他们在1966年在肯辛顿教堂街开了新店，
And it's full of tie-dyed stuff and maroon scarves and very dark colors. So it looks completely different from anything else. And she is well ahead of the game on all this. So Bieber is very cool to that extent. So in other words, it's selling the fashion of 1968 three or four years early. And by the end of the 60s it's it's the most fashionable the most celebrated of all london's clothing shops so it gets celebrities kind of julie christie brigitte bardot marianne faithful they come and shop there it's very cheap they open a new store in 1966 in kensington church
正如一位记者所说，估计每周有3000只多莉鸟推开沉重的维多利亚式木门和铜门，打算把她们最后的先令花在里面那个阿拉丁洞穴中诱人的服饰小玩意上。她们遭受了巨大的问题，像所有这些商店一样，是入店行窃。因为那种时髦感，你知道……
street as one journalist puts it an estimated estimated 3,000 dolly birds each week push through the heavy Victorian wood and brass doors intent on dissipating their last shillings on the tempting sartorial baubles of the Aladdin's cave that lies within. They suffer massive problems, like all these shops do, with shoplifting. So because of the sort of grooviness, you know...
是的，因为这太……我的意思是，阻止人们入店行窃是非常“蓝色怪人”的行为。没错。非常古板。没错。他们搬进了越来越大的商店。所以他们在1969年搬进了肯辛顿高街的一家。
Yeah, because it's far too... I mean, that's very blue meanies to have people stopping you shoplifting. Exactly. Very square. Exactly. And they move into bigger and bigger shops. So they move into one in Kensington High Street in 1969.
那里面有埃及柱子和大理石地板。他们每周有10万名顾客。他们的营业额是百货公司的四倍。他们在卖，你在卖太阳镜、靴子。这是嬉皮士造型的典范。你想要一条羽毛围巾，汤姆。你要去参加你的活动之一。你要去参加一个图书活动来宣传你关于罗马人的新历史。
And that has got Egyptian columns and it's marble floors. They get 100,000 customers a week. Their turnover is four times that of a department store. They are selling, you are selling sunglasses, boots. It's the hippie look par excellence. You want a feather boa, Tom. You're going to one of your events. You're going to a book event to publicize your new history of the Romans.
你可能会戴领结，羽毛围巾。这有点像吉米·亨德里克斯的造型。你会粘上那些爱德华时代的鬓角。你会戴某种软帽，一种吉米·亨德里克斯正是那种造型，厚底鞋，厚底鞋，因为我开始变异成埃尔顿·约翰了，不是吗？这就是事实，70年代初，等待着的时尚，是的，或者对于英国听众来说，等待你的命运是彼得·温加德饰演的杰森·金，那是，你基本上，等待你的命运是彼得·温加德饰演的杰森·金。你会变成那样。
You might wear a cravat, a feather boa. It's kind of Jimi Hendrix look. You'd have glued on those Edwardian sideburns. You'd be wearing a kind of floppy hat of some kind a sort of jimmy hendrix is exactly the look platform heels platform heels because i'm starting to mutate into elton john aren't i and that's the truth the seven early 70s the fashion that is waiting yeah or for or for british listeners you're basically the fate that awaits you is peter wingard as jason king that's, you're basically, the fate that awaits you is Peter Wingard as Jason King. That's what you're going to turn into.
是的。这一切都很令人沮丧。约翰·莱顿会鄙视你。是的，他会。这就是你要变成的样子。他会。所以Biba搬进了一系列越来越大的地点。然后在1973年，它搬进了肯辛顿高街的前德里和汤姆百货公司。大Biba是自第二次世界大战以来伦敦第一家新的百货公司。它绝对是在亏损。我想它在1975年关闭了。
Yes. It's all very depressing. And John Lydon will despise you. Yeah, he will. That is what you're turning into. He will. So Bieber moved into a succession of ever bigger locations. And then in 1973, it moved into the former Derry and Tom's department store on Kensington High Street. Big Bieber was the first new department store in London since the Second World War. And it's absolutely losing money hand over fist. And it closes, I think, 1975, I think.
就是这样。梦想结束了。结束了，所以在那一点上，70年代初，60年代的造型已经变得，显然现在没有人穿迷你裙，也没有人画那种睫毛膏眼睛和崔姬的造型，我的意思是所有这些人已经从头条新闻中消失了，造型非常颓废，有点，你知道，在70年代初非常过度华丽和过度郁郁葱葱，然后朋克是这个场景，是一股巨大的新鲜空气。我们应该做一个关于朋克的完整播客。因为我认为朋克的遗产在服饰、设计和文化方面比在音乐方面要大得多。而且我认为朋克的造型实际上可以说比声音更重要。
And that's it. The dream is over. over so at that point the early 70s the 60s look has become obviously nobody now is wearing mini skirts and is wearing sort of the mascaraed eyes and the twiggy look i mean all these these people have disappeared from the headlines the look is very decadent and sort of uh you know it's very over glamorous and over kind of lush and stuff in the early 70s and And then punk is this scene, is this tremendous breath of fresh air. And we should do a whole podcast about punk. Because I think punk's legacy is far more sartorial and design and kind of culture broadly than it is musical. And I think the look of punk is actually arguably more important even than the sound.
虽然朋克反过来被新浪漫主义者取代，他们又回望爱德华和维多利亚时代，所以循环当然在继续，然后你又回到了领结和软帽，你可以拿出来，我的意思是，你不能再拿出你的爱德华鬓角了，汤姆，但是，如果你戴上你在Biba买的围巾，如果还有的话，1982年，是的，去和乔治男孩混在一起，是的，完全正确，完全正确，所以我猜到那时，到80年代，60年代的时尚已经被吸收进了旋转门，然后进入90年代，你又有了摩德族回归，完全正确，它只是被无休止地循环利用，我的意思是，我认为那些认为在音乐、时尚和设计方面我们稍微陷入了一种无休止重复循环的人是有道理的。
Although punk in turn gets replaced by new romantics, who again are looking back at kind of the edwardian victorian and so the cycle continues of course and then you're back to the cravats and the and the floppy hats and you can get out i mean you can't get out your edwardian sideburns again tom but the uh if i were the boa that you that you'll abort in biba that comes back if you've still got it 1982 yep go and hang out with boy george and yeah exactly exactly so i suppose by that point by the 80s 60s fashion has been absorbed into the the revolving door that is and then into the 90s you get the mods come back and exactly and it just becomes endlessly recycled i mean i think there is a reasonable case those those people who argue that in music and fashion and design that we're slightly stuck in a kind of an endlessly repeating cycle.
我认为那是真的，不是吗？我们仍然生活在阴影中。嗯，这就是60年代的兴奋点，不是吗？有一种真正的感觉，界限正在被打破，新的视野正在打开，即使你可能对此持怀疑态度。但我的意思是，有一种感觉，人们以前从未这样打扮过，这就是迷你裙的兴奋点，因此正如你指出的那样，墨尔本战役具有巨大的历史意义，而在这一点上，你和我会有分歧，我想汤姆，我们在《其余皆是历史》中总是有的那种有趣的争论，你可能对其中的思想和知识层面更感兴趣，而
I think that's true, isn't it? That we still live in the shadow. Well, that's the excitement of the 60s, isn't it? There is a genuine feeling that boundaries are being pushed and that new horizons are opening up, even if you may be skeptical about that. But I mean, there is a sense that people have never looked like this before uh that's the excitement of the miniskirt hence the vast historical significance of the battle of melbourne as you pointed out and where you and i would disagree i think tom our fun disagreement that we always have in the rest of this history is you would probably be more interested in the ideas and the the intellectual side of that and
我认为这一切最终是由金钱和经济驱动的。不，我绝不否认这一点，我认为时尚绝对是由金钱驱动的。但你更，你总是更感兴趣，你知道，你更……你喜欢抽象名词。我确实喜欢抽象名词。在欧洲历史的广阔视野中，我的意思是，绝对地，我认为思想的影响力要大得多。但在60年代时尚的背景下，我认为金钱，我完全接受你的论点。我的意思是，我读过你关于它的书。我毫不怀疑金钱是驱动它的因素。但话虽如此，你需要创造力和主动性以及原创性的原材料，这正是你在60年代得到的。这就是为什么我们做了两个关于60年代时尚的节目，而不是，比如说，关于70年代、80年代或90年代的时尚。而且我认为60年代也给了我们一些我们从未失去的东西。我看不出为什么或什么时候我们会失去它，那就是青春崇拜。人们在60年代如此多地谈论它，这标志着它是多么新颖。青春的想法，以前，我想，与经济力量的缺乏联系在一起，稍微认为青春，青春现在感到受困
i think that's all actually ultimately driven by money and by the economy no i i don't in any way dispute that i think that that fashion is absolutely driven by money but you're more you're always more interested in you know you're more um you like an abstract noun i do like an abstract noun in the broad sweep of uh european history i mean absolutely i think that um the influence of ideas is vastly more influential. But I think in the context of 60s fashion, I think money, I completely buy your thesis. I mean, I read your books on it. I have no doubt that money is what is driving it. But having said that, you need the raw material of creativity and initiative and originality, which is what you
了，虽然是的，以一种以前没有过的方式，是的，我认为这是一个公平的观点。经济对年轻人不利，是的，事实上，当然，在60年代年轻的人现在正住在他们极其昂贵的房子里，拿着养老金。是的，你是对的。我们现在已经陷入了普遍的酒吧谈话。但我认为你可以合理地争辩说，他们是历史上最幸运的一代。是的，你可以这么说。婴儿潮一代。
do get in the 60s. And that's why we've done two programs on the fashion of the 60s and not, say, on the fashion of the 70s, 80s, or 90s. And I think the 60s also gives us something that we've never lost. I can't see why or when we would lose it, which is the cult of youth. The fact that people remark on it so much in the 60s is a sign of how novel it is. The idea that youth, which previously, I guess, was associated with a sign of how novel it is the idea that that youth which previously i guess was associated with a lack of economic power slightly think that youth youth feels embattled
即使你不是卡纳比街的常客，当然99%的人都不是，你也可以说是享受了，我的意思是，当然有起有落，但你也可以说是享受了比之前或之后任何一代人都更大的声望，更大的文化声望和更大的经济机会。好吧，以那个愉快的音符结束，如果你是一位年长的听众，而如果你是一位年轻的听众，这是一个令人沮丧的音符。我们最好把卡纳比街留在身后，继续前进。所以汤姆，选一个造型。我是男的还是女的？
now though yes in a way that hasn't done before yeah i think that's a fair point the kind of economy is against younger people yeah and in fact of course it's the people who were young in the 60s who are now squatting in their enormously expensive houses and with their pensions. Yeah, you're right. We've now spiraled off into general kind of slum bar conversation. But I think you can reasonably argue they're the most fortunate generation in history. Yeah, you could do. The boomers.
这是你的选择。女的。我绝对会选戴安娜·里格。是的，我会选那个。穿着迷你裙踢拳击。绝对。绝对。
Even if you weren't a Carnaby Street habituate, which of course 99% of people aren't uh you've arguably enjoyed i mean of course there have been ups and downs but you've arguably enjoyed greater prestige great greater cultural prestige and greater economic opportunity than any generation before or since well on that cheery note if you are an elderly listener and depressing note if you are a younger listener. We'd better leave Carnaby Street behind and groove off. So Tom, choose a look. Am I male or female?
那正是我想要看到的，我们会看起来很可爱，我们会成为一对可爱的人。所以《星期日泰晤士报》想把我们打扮成亨利八世和他的妻子们拍照，是的，我反对它，但如果他们说了，如果1962年开创性的《星期日泰晤士报》彩色版块的后代说，我们想让你打扮成玛丽·匡特。哦，那是简·施林普顿和崔姬，汤姆。是的。我会非常乐意那样做。而且实际上，这对其他彩色副刊来说是一个常设邀请。
It's your choice. Female. I would definitely Diana Rigg. Yeah, that's what I'd go for. Kickboxing in miniskirts. Absolutely. Absolutely.
多米尼克，我的意思是，我不想冒犯。我不想听起来粗鲁，但我认为你会成为一个不可能的崔姬。我会是简·施林普顿。我绝对会是简·施林普顿。我认为反直觉地做是唯一的方法，汤姆。好吧。好吧。嗯，这是一个可怕的想法，
That's exactly what I would like to see we'd look lovely we'd make a lovely pair so the sunday times wanted to photograph us dressed up as henry the eighth and his wives yeah i was against it but if they had said if the descendant of the pioneering sunday times color section of 1962 had said we want you to dress as Mary Quant. Oh, it's Gene Strimpton and Twiggy, Tom. Yeah. I would have been so up for that. And actually, that's a standing invitation to other colour supplements.
一个听众可能很难从脑海中抹去的心理形象。是的。非常感谢你们的收听。谢谢你，多米尼克，为我们带来了对摇摆伦敦的精彩回顾。我们很快就会回来。再见。
Dominic, I mean, I don't want to be offensive. I don't want to sound rude, but I think you'd make an improbable Twiggy. I'd be Gene Strimpton. I would absolutely be Gene Strimpton. I think do it counterintuitively is the only way to do it, Tom. Okay. Okay. Well, there's a terrifying thought,
再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《其余皆是娱乐》。这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
a mental image that listeners may find hard to get out of their head. Yeah. Thank you very much for listening. Thank you, Dominic for brilliant sweep through, through swinging London. And we'll be back very soon. Bye-bye.
如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和优先购买现场票的权益，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。前往 therestisentertainment.com。就是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。